can you tell the difference between coke
and a pepsi i suspect that most of you
guys would say yes
i know that i'm gonna be able to tell
the difference no problem no questions
asked but statistically this is not true
in fact the average person's ability to
differentiate between the two is not
much better than random chance
researchers have been studying this
phenomenon for decades at this point
with one of the first studies coming
from the university of wichita in the
first part of the study participants
were given coca-cola pepsi and rc cola
and they were asked to guess which one
was which only 41 percent of
participants were able to correctly
identify coca-cola while 38 identified
pepsi and 35 identified rc cola off the
bat these aren't very good results given
that the majority failed to identify any
of them correctly but this gets way
worse when we take a look at the second
part of the study the researchers had a
feeling that the reason more people were
able to guess coca-cola correctly was
not because they were able to tell the
difference but simply because they were
more likely to guess coca-cola to
confirm this the researchers gave the
participants three cups of the same soda
without telling them that it was the
same soda and then the participants were
asked to identify which one was which as
you would guess the results were quite
similar to that of the first part 45 of
participants were able to correctly
identify coca-cola while 32 percent
identified pepsi and 25 identified rc
cola but while most people cannot
statistically tell the difference
between coca-cola and pepsi 71 say that
they would choose coke over pepsi one of
the top reasons they cite for this
preference is a seemingly larger
caffeine boost which is quite ironic
given that pepsi is the one with more
caffeine clearly coke has won the
branding wars by a mile but the funny
part is that it's not just competitors
who can't overcome coke's branding even
coca-cola themselves can't overcome
coke's branding so here's the most
notable attempts of companies trying to
beat coke and why they all failed
likely one of the most valiant efforts
against coke's dominance was the pepsi
challenge which made its debut in the
mid-1970s by this point pepsi and coke
had already been fighting for market
share for over 70 years
yet it seemed like coke always had the
upper hand no matter what adds pepsi ran
who they marketed to or what
endorsements they had the majority of
people simply chose coke this made pepsi
quite mad not just because all of their
efforts were wasted but because they
strongly believed that they had the
superior product they hadn't just run a
few dozen or even a few hundred taste
tests pepsi had run it three thousand
blind taste tests and the majority
preferred pepsi so in 1975 pepsi would
publicly call out coke for having
inferior taste and challenge viewers to
participate in the pepsi challenge they
set up pop-up taste tests at malls
department stores parks basically
anywhere they could and they had random
people blindly taste pepsi and coke side
by side
as you would guess most of them would
choose pepsi and pepsi would film their
live reactions and compile them into
commercials these commercials were
actually super effective as many people
decided to give pepsi a shot in fact by
1983 pepsi was outselling coke in
supermarkets there's rumors that after
seeing the success of the pepsi
challenge coca-cola started filming
their own coke challenge but they never
aired this footage because the majority
of participants actually ended up
choosing pepsi so it doesn't look like
pepsi was faking their results but
despite this pepsi was never able to
overtake coca-cola in overall market
share the closest they got was in 1980
when pepsi's market share hovered in the
high 20s and coca-cola's market share
hovered in the mid-30s one of the key
reasons for this was coca-cola's far
larger beach thanks to the dominance
among soda machines and fast food
restaurants but why coca-cola was able
to keep their lead the pepsi challenge
definitely hurt their ego and it
wouldn't be long until they fired back
with their own new product
in the early 1980s coca-cola began
running their own into on taste tests
but instead of having people choose
between pepsi and coke they had people
choose between pepsi coke and a new
formulation of coke clearly coca-cola
was convinced that their original
product was starting to lose its flair
and that it was time to revamp their
formula
this was obviously a bold move and
coca-cola definitely did not take this
task lightly they spent years tweaking
the flavor and they conducted 190 000
blind taste tests and it wasn't until
they could definitively prove that their
new formulation was the preferred taste
that they decided to make the change and
with that on april 23rd in 1985
coca-cola ceo roberto guizueta proudly
announced the launch of a new coke
despite their grand expectations though
new coke started hitting obstacles from
the second it was launched first of all
the launch of new coke itself was an
admission that pepsi did in fact have a
superior product and secondly new coke
was noticeably sweeter than the original
coke just like pepsi and this was yet
another admission that pepsi was right
all along pepe's executives were
ecstatic after 87 years they had finally
gotten a response out of coca-cola
pepsi's executives were actually so
hyped that they gave their employees the
rest of the day off meanwhile
coca-cola's executives were also super
optimistic the ceo called new coke the
surest move ever made and the president
declared that new cook was the most
confident decision he had ever made
while cook was publicly admitting that
pepsi was right they now had a product
that was definitively better there's no
way 190 000 taste tests were wrong
right well the taste tests were indeed
most likely accurate but consumers
didn't care coke fans did not want a
better coke they just wanted coke and
given that coca-cola had discontinued
their old version consumers had no
choice but to voice their opinions
in the weeks following the announcement
5 000 customers call the company on a
daily basis requesting that original
coke was brought back within a few
months this number actually grew to 8
000 calls per day which forced coca-cola
to hire more phone operators
aside from all these angry phone calls
people were publicly showcasing their
hatred for new coke for example
consumers across america were pouring
new coke down sewer drains and one guy
in seattle even filed a lawsuit against
coca-cola to bring back the original
coke of course this lawsuit didn't go
anywhere but it was a clear sign of just
how much people despise the move
at first coca-cola tried to ignore the
resistance as much as possible likely
thinking that it would just go away
sooner or later but as the resistance
just continued to get stronger coca-cola
finally gave in just 79 days after
announcing a new coke the president of
coca-cola declared that while they had
believed that new coke was the way
forward in the end their boss is the
consumer and it was clear what the
consumer wanted coca-cola would go on to
bring back the original recipe as coke
classic and if you've ever wondered why
old bottles of coke say the word classic
on them this is why
almost instantaneously the original
formula would overtake the new formula
in sales and regain its position as the
world's most popular soda coca-cola
didn't just kill off new coke though
they rebranded new coke as coke 2 in
1990 and they kept it around till 2002
while this was likely not a very fun
experience for coca-cola this actually
turned out to be a massive benefit the
time away from original coke showed
people just how much they liked the soda
and the loyalty to the drink became
stronger than ever before the positive
outcome has prompted many to speculate
whether the entire fiasco was planned
from the beginning but i think
coca-cola's former president says it
best the truth is that we're not that
dumb and we're not that smart
in retrospect it's clear that neither
pepsi nor coca-cola's attempts at
displacing the original soda were
successful but
why every statistic that we know tells
us that new coke and pepsi tasted better
and that people can't even identify the
drink based on the taste so why in the
world was there such a negative reaction
to new coke well the answer boils down
to two parts the logical side and the
emotional side from a logical
perspective you could argue that a taste
test is not a very good measure of what
people would like to drink on a regular
basis
one of the main reasons that pepsi and
new cook performed better in taste tests
was because they were both sweeter and
when you're only tasting a few sips of
each soda most people are naturally
going to choose a soda that's sweeter
but when we're talking about a full can
of soda or even multiple cans it's
likely that people reach flavor fatigue
much faster with the sweeter soda as a
result while people may prefer sweeter
options in a taste test they tend to
prefer classic coke over the long term
the only problem with this line of
reasoning though is that it assumes that
people can discern between coke and
pepsi which is statistically not true
now of course if you're drinking pepsi
and coke side by side like the taste
testers you can likely tell that they
don't taste exactly alike but if you
were randomly given one or the other you
likely wouldn't be able to correctly
guess which one you were given
considering this people's preference for
classic coke likely has less to do with
logical reasoning and more to do with
emotional reasoning and a great example
of this is the results of yet another
study in this study the researchers gave
participants two bottles of soda one was
labeled with the letter l while the
other was labeled with the letter s but
the contents of the two bottles were
identical given that it's the same soda
there should theoretically be no
difference between people's preference
for either soda yet participants
overwhelmingly prefer the soda with the
letter s the explanation for this is
actually that the average person tends
to like the letter s more than the
letter l meaning that it has nothing to
do with the soda itself some researchers
further proved this by giving people
pepsi in a coke bottle and coke in a
pepsi bottle and the participants didn't
notice so clearly taste was not the
factor that was holding back any of
these sodas
in the end i think the main reason that
pepsi no coca-cola nor any other sort of
brand can ever displace classic coke is
due to nostalgia in our extremely
fast-paced world everything around us is
rapidly changing we don't have the same
phones or computers that we had 10 years
ago but we all still drink the same soda
that our parents and their parents drink
and as we all grow older soda is one of
the few things that we come across on a
regular basis that reminds us of our
childhood and how things used to be for
example i wasn't around when new cook
came out but i do specifically remember
an instance relating to classic coke way
back in 2007 i was at sea world and we
had both coke and sprite cans and i
remember wondering why the coke cans had
a classic but the sprite can didn't i
was only 5 years old at the time and i
remember being sad that my drink of
choice sprite was not a classic it
wasn't till 10 years later that i
actually found out what the classic
meant and now whenever i hear about new
coke or cool classic i always think
about going to seaworld as a kid i
suspect that this nostalgic feeling is
way stronger for someone who's 50 70 90
years old coke is one of the few things
that remind them of their own childhoods
way back in the 1930s or 40s and as long
as coke carries this nostalgic
significance it's gonna be nearly
impossible to displace do you guys like
coke or pepsi comment that down below
also drop a like if soda carries some
sort of nostalgic significance for you
and of course consider checking out our
international channels to watch your
videos in other languages and consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered but until then i'm
hari and i'll see you guys on the next
one